thank you, president, president, ladies and gentlemen,
we are in one of the most
important debates and they are going to mark the entire
European legislature but also the
future of the union. It is useless to set
the objectives between now and 2050 if we
tie our hands for the next
seven years that we are  at a
crucial moment for europe we all
also know the council that europe
really needs to launch a great
transformation to lead in
sustainability in the world a
transformation in economic
social environmental matters of course that
this agenda of transformation is
necessary we all know it  and also the
council now we just need to be
able to put on the table
the necessary means to carry it
out the proposal of this parliament is
very reasonable and addresses this need with
13 percent of the gross national
product plus additional resources for
and policies that have to be put in
place how to deal with the transition just
In this matter, the proposal of this
parliament is very clear and has a large
majority of support from the
different political groups. The president,
Bandar la Gent, has insisted a lot on
the need for this to be a
geostrategic commission and for us to have
our position  in the world and also
the president of the council, michelle sanz,
has alluded to the need to
lead the fight for climate neutrality
in the world, now all that is
needed is for you to convince your council partners
and I also want to say at this time
that we  I would have liked Mr.
these michelles to be here today, perhaps he
still has little to say but he has a
lot to listen to convince the
members of the council I think it is necessary to
understand the great responsibility
that we face and it is necessary to have
an agreement in front of us  that there are no
winners and losers because then
Europe will be losing this is not about
taking money away from policies to
put  ing it to others this is not about taking
money away from the regions and putting it into
others I want to remind you of one thing here that it
was Jacques Delors who launched
the first multi-annual program and he did it
bearing in mind that it was necessary
to create a great European agenda and that
It had to be above
national interests that it was much more
important to advance in the solidarity of
the European project and that is the ambition
that we must have at this time
to the heads of government a
European vision because we are in an
important moment and we are  also playing right
now the future of the union project it
is important that we understand that it
is necessary to address once and for
all the discourse of
own resources for those additional funds that we
need is a strong and
ambitious budget we cannot do more with less we
need  address European policies
for young people we need to
address European policies for the
primary sector for  farmers and
for ranchers we need to address
European policy to support
new entrepreneurs and
researchers there are so many
policies that Europe
can respond to right now that we are not going to give
up trying to continue with this
issue time passes and the  the clock is ticking
and for us we can say this
parliament is patient i
am going to say two last questions the
parliament decides on equal
terms together with the council and we
are not going to give in to the pressure of time
because the future of the european union
is in our hands and  it is the
most important responsibility that
we have at the moment thank you very much